I was at the DMV the girl in front of me
moved from Indiana so she's getting like
a new license New State we were talking
chopped it up got each other's number
we're at the food court he's kind of
just breaking down like yeah I did move
out here because I was in a relationship
he mentioned that it was a little
abusive
I was like I was I was playing the
superhero role you'll never go through
something like that again
I was like let's go like shoot some pool
but she wanted to go back her apartment
first she wanted to change I mean we're
already kind of like out but y'all we go
and I'm in her room then there's a knock
on the door right she didn't acknowledge
it and I thought that that was weird so
then the knock happened again I'm like
yo there's someone at your door and she
was just like it's all good like that
now the knock is getting like
so she goes to like look it's him and
I'm like who's him my ex the one who did
this and she's like showing like a scar
I'm like
why don't you show me that food court
the fingerprint is like this big